right yep doing the right thing this
will do it
this will do it scott drew's dream comes
true
coach drew and baylor complete college
basketball's greatest rebound
and rebuild with a championship
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
gonzaga huddles together one last time
as a team
the heartbreak they must feel and but
they just went into weight
ran into a buzz saw this team but
jesus chris talk about butler or any of
the others
the preparation the defensive scheme
afraid of the moment any of them not
afraid at all the contrast and emotions
on display here
the celebration the feeling of dejection
from gonzaga
we have a new champion and scott drew
said he found the calling on friday
he is a champion indeed here monday
night
we came to win games in the ncaa
tournament he set back in o3 that clip
we played
we came here with a chance to win the
ncaa championship
and tonight in indianapolis they've done
that
in resounding fashion
vital taking a rest after eight
offensive rebounds he deserves it
11 rebounds all total hey he
this is what he wanted to do he signed
with him after his sophomore year in
high school
i guess he wanted to go there he wanted
to be a part of it came back an extra
year he's 24 years old
it was all about coming back and winning
a championship sure did they
absolutely dominate saturday and monday
and proved to the nation that they
are the best in the land the 2021
national champions
baylor university bears
studio's coming up next